John maybe we can start with you though
because I'm curious after the film in
2009 when Jim and you felt you had
another story to tell you know we felt
when we were making the first avatar
that if the movie was successful there
were more stories to tell with these
characters set on Pandora to be honest
when the movie was done and we were
finished and we had the incredible
success that Beyond anyone's imagination
um we needed time to digest Jim took two
years and he built a submarine to
explore the Mariana Trench and it was
after that in 2012 that we really sat
down and felt that there was enough
stories to justify making more than one
Sequel and Jim took a year and wrote
1500 pages of story notes and we then
brought on three teams of writers to
create sort of like a writer's room
which is something unusual
and broke down those 1500 pages of notes
into the scripts that that you see now
well I think we can all acknowledge it's
an extraordinary film and we're so glad
that everyone came back for it
so this entire team has worked with Jim
before either on the previous Avatar or
on another one of his films so I'm
curious when you knew this movie was
really going to happen and the following
sequels what you anticipated to be the
most difficult part of your job I
represent
a very large editorial team including
Jim myself John Murphy and our dearly
departed David Brenner
and two additional editors Jason gotio
and Ian silver iron Silverstein and
editorial on an Avatar movie
is unlike editorial on any other movie
and we are there from the very beginning
when performances are captured
we put together performance edits that
are approved and meticulously selected
performances
and those shots and scenes are prepared
for virtual photography which create
the template for each scene and in this
particular film with the enormous amount
of live-action integration into virtual
character scenes
we had to capture a placeholder for
every live-action character
that would ultimately be replaced with
live action photography
so we had many stages of editing
throughout this process over the years
and it is it is a very complicated
process
um Russell I'm curious for you when you
came on especially with the water part
of this story how did you anticipate
that would make your job harder
well I've had a little experience with
water before with it with Jim and I knew
it was going to be difficult and and
that part was uh I came into it
basically though I came under this show
as a as a newcomer and basically I
thought well here we have a there's
already a template for what Pandora
looks like and when I talked with Jim
about how we were going to expand on
this he says well we have a lot of new
worlds here to look at and we talked
about the very very nuanced light that
you find in the forces Forest of Pandora
Under The Canopy uh nothing the light
was going to be living
breathing as much as the planet did that
uh there were going to be very much uh
very many different colors uh and that
canopy and then we have a world of the
RDA which is its own its own language of
of light so basically I started off by
lighting some scenes uh supervising some
scenes with the lighting and uh uh I'm
very happy with the way those went uh
while I was doing that uh I was uh
prepping cameras there was uh there was
so much new technology and then I also
had to speak the language of virtual too
and there there was this uh this wedding
of uh the live action photography and
the virtual teams and uh we had a few
bumps but eventually it went very well
and we were very supportive of each
other and I just want to clarify Russ
when you talk about the lighting in a
year of lighting we brought Russ on a
year before we got to our live action
filming because we wanted him to be a
part of the lighting style of what we
call the virtual world the pandoran
world so Russell you know is is the
auteur who who came in and gave his
sensibility for the lighting because we
needed to match it in the live action so
that's why when he refers to that yeah
so Dylan tell me about creating the
world of the Met kaina because I think
it's so unique but feels authentic to
what that culture if it existed would
look like yeah creating that world was
Far and Away the the biggest challenge
on on my side of things for for
production design and real quick I just
want to explain we have two production
designers myself and Ben Proctor and
it's divided along the lines of I
basically am in charge of all things
Pandora
um environments you know cultural
creatures all that stuff and Ben is in
charge of everything human it's all the
RDA you know human sets and vehicles and
all that so on my side the the mechanic
Village is Far and Away the most
difficult Jim had a basic idea of these
large mangroves and there would be a
village suspended underneath it
and beyond that it was up to us to
figure it out you know like Jim has a
has a has a vision but trying to realize
that and bring that into reality was Far
and Away the biggest challenge and so we
did many types of Explorations we did a
lot of practical Explorations where we
would build tensile models even going so
far as to engage what a workshop into
building a large-scale miniature of of
the Salim rui the the the the Sully's
home at metcaina where
um we engaged the best Weavers in New
Zealand and we wove a home and bent came
and did this for real and figured this
stuff out for real
um you know even after rigor's design
process in Los Angeles with
illustrations and 3D models still didn't
like okay that's great let's test this
and let's do this for real and weave it
and
um
while that was not a shooting miniature
it became the Practical reference and
the standard of photorealism that that
the visual effects had to be held up to
and that and some other walkway studies
informed the entire Village and so um in
Avatar one there wasn't a big
architectural Focus
um they lived in hometry and there was
some you know some props and some
hammocks and a few things but this was
getting way more into knobby design and
we see how the mechania are much more
advanced Weavers
um you know and it was very important is
to show cultural differences and to show
that there is diversity on this large
Moon we think of it a plant but it's a
moon and that um it was important to
separate those those cultures and to see
how they draw inspiration from the sea
and that that is part of their life you
know and that connectivity is a huge
huge theme for us so the whole walkway
system is all tensile structured
literally connecting everything there
just as they are connected to the ocean
just how in the oceans we you know
connect it with the fractal core oral
shapes and all the sinuous shapes and
the roots of the spirit tree so we're
really
trying to find that diversity but then
also finding the common themes of
connectivity which is you know one of
the major things we see in Avatar and
Deborah what did Jim ask of you on this
one that you had to deliver oh my
goodness Jim has such a vivid and
immense imagination which is at once out
of a huge like oh my God what a task
that will be but he also just opens the
door to every creative bone in your body
so we're so fortunate to have him as our
leader and inspiration really
um so you know it was it was a big
project I was the costume designer for
Live Action and for the virtual world I
did we did all the performance capture
we did a you know we had to shoot
reference upon reference upon reference
but most importantly I think Jim's most
important
thing to me was we were going to make
every single one of those virtual
costumes that that the way they were
made how they were made how they were
worn was to inform the digital and VFX
team so
it was daunting and it was marvelous it
was absolutely the best fun I've ever
had
how did you first approach the score I
mean it sounds like authenticity was
such a key part of a lot of these
conversations was that the same for you
yes I think Jim asked me to read all of
the scripts in December 2017. and on the
first paragraph of two it says naturi
sings the song chord which is this and
this was a thread that wove itself
through the film and so I had this
immediate thing that said to me music is
important to this film and it has a
reason to exist so my first task was to
write the song chord for Nigeria to sing
um and I looked at that and one of the
things we were working in a Thing Called
Culture Club which was the idea that Jim
said you just can't make stuff up I
wanted to write this in in Navi not in
English it had to feel grounded in
Pandora so I started looking around the
world at various different uh indigenous
Customs to do with birth and death and
so on and there's one that resonated
with me with this and it occurs all over
the world is the idea of a spark
being starting and then the dawn coming
and you carry the light with you through
the day and then eventually you go to
the Sunset and I use that as my sort of
home for the lyric I then had to give
this lyric to Jim I wrote it in English
first I said Tim this is where I want to
be and then I translated it roughly into
Navi and then worked with Paul from the
chief linguist and designer of the navi
language once I had the song chord I
started thinking about other themes that
were to go through the film because you
know there are obviously there are the
family is the core of the music in this
and you can see that in the way that the
song chord then expanded into a theme as
they're leaving home tree you actually
hear the song chord but it's a big
orchestral theme
but there's also there is the Sea and
the mechanina and their connection
um and that became a theme that I used
um for when they're swimming underwater
the first time and when the tolkun
arrived and I had one other massive
responsibility in some ways in that
because so much of this happens
underwater
there isn't any dialogue and the sound
effects are so relatively minimal so in
some ways sometimes I had to be that
extra character the music had to act as
an extra character within the film and
so there were certain scenes where Jim
would say to me we have to do this again
you know we would redo these things many
times There is five hours of finished
score music has always meant something
to a Jim Cameron film and I think this
was one of those times where he he
challenged me he pushed me and I think
um you know that was part of what you
know it had to be woven into the film so
13 years since the last film came out
what did time allow you in making this
film successful what was it it's the
best gift having this much time gave to
you time allowed us to present what you
saw today
I don't think we could have done this
five years ago I don't think we could
have done this and I I think that you
know
Cinema
that word Cinema
we all have to fight to preserve it in
in today's world and that was really one
of our goals was to create something
when when audiences around the world go
to see Avatar the way of water they are
reminded of just how special the movie
going experience can be one of the lines
Jim wrote on the first avatar it's in
this one again enate kamea I see you and
each movie
is designed about seeing things and
seeing people for who they are and
appreciating that
well thank you so much for joining us
please give him another round of event
thank you very much